فيلم خيال الشعبي ارتبطت عمليات الانقاذ
في الفضاء بشطحات خيال افلامه فالى اي مدن
يمكن ان ينطبق ذلك واقعيا على عمليات
الانقاذ في الفضاء
منذ شهر ثلاثه رواد فضاء روسيان وامريكي
صغير مركبه الفضاء الروسيه الشهر الماضي
واحدث ثقبا قطره اقل من ملم واحد مما تسبب
في تسرب سائل التبريد من المركبه المتصله
بمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
على طاقم المحطه الفضائيه الا انها اثارت
مخاوفه بشان ما اذا كان بامكانهم العوده
الى الارض في هذه الحاله بعد تحليل الموقف
ومناقشته مع وكاله ناسا قررت وكاله الفضاء
الروسيه اطلاق كبسولات جديده في الوضع
التلقائي بدون طاقم في ال 20 من فبراير
لاعادتهم راس كوزموس اوضحت انه اذا نشا
موقف حرج بشكل خاص على محطه الفضاء
الدوليه في الاسابيع التي تسبق وصول
المركبه الجديده فسيتم النظر في امكانيه
استخدام المركبه المتضرره لانقاذ الطقم
وكان رواد الفضاء الروسيان سيرجي
بروكوبيان
والامريكي فرانك روبيو قد وصلوا الى
المحطه في سبتمبر علمتني سويوز ايماست 22
وخطط طول استخدام الكبسوله للعوده الى
الارض لكن تسريب السائل التبريد رافع
درجات حراره الكبسوله مما اثار المخاوف من
انها اصبحت غير امنه لنقل رواد الفضاء الى
الارض وهكذا سيبقى الثلاثه في المدار الان
الى حين وصول المركبه التي من المامول ان
تعيدهم الى كوكب الارضي سالمين